nous sommes avec jean-louis font ça vous
êtes historien vous avez travaillé
beaucoup sur l'insurrection du sud où
sommes-nous d'abord pour commencer nous
sommes le quartier sainte-croix body la
cabaude et c'est un lieu j'ai des
histoires la mesure où cette zone qui
est exécuté le colon béquille godet en
1966 lors de l'insurrection du sud
donc ce quartier symbolique même si en
croix derrière notre dos qui symbolise
l'exécution tous les catholiques
en fait c'est un haut lieu où vous avez
vu de ce lieu nous avons une vue
panoramique sur l'ensemble du sud est de
8 pilotes et pour bien le caractère
jeudi un massif d'insurrection tous ces
gens du sud qui se sont mobilisés en
1870 et pour demander la fin de cette
période qui d extrêmement difficile et
peut-être aussi que l'âgisme qui n'avait
rien changé dans le mode de vie ou leur
mode de travail ni leur mode de
communication donc alors tout à l'heure
on l'a vu
on a vu un petit peu l'épisode
déclencheur
à
l'habitation
grands fonds marins est ce que vous nous
expliquer un petit peu le contexte
politique et social de l'époque
alors alors nous sommes en 1870 vingt
deux ans après il ya ce sont des
esclaves alors 2 1 mais pas autant ce
qui se passe en france et sexas sandra
tic
en france on a eu la république ensuite
à hull empire libéral lempire
dictatorial et la guerre des mois franco
prussienne 2100 62170 en martinique la
période libérale
le week-end a duré que deux ans et dès
1852 lempire gelé dictatorial de
septembre ethnique les conseils
municipaux sont abolies et les colons
devient évidemment les gestionnaires des
communes et du patrimoine cultuel
bâtiment foncière donc rien n'a changé
donc qu'ils appliquent à la lettre les
arrêter des décisions prises lors de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
qu'est ce que c'est premièrement c'est
que les anciens esclaves
damman devenus ouvriers mais ils sont
directement affectés sur les plantations
ils doivent se déplacer avant impasse
près de passeport pour qui se place de
ces cadeaux commune d'habitation
invitation donc c'est un peu les parce
qu'on connaît cependant la partie
en cas contraire si on ne lisait pas
leurs passes il était condamné pour
délit de vagabondage epn et pour d'autre
part les habitations suivre y font
faillite et les terres sont nombreux
membres et l'adour concentré et
l'apparition des usines centrales les
grosses usines le martin lartigue
basse-pointe ont mis environ 22 usines
centrales construites en cette période
et les petits propriétaires colombier
gaven et font faillite
ils vendent leurs auteurs ou 10 km lors
des augmentations dans quelques autres
concentration foncière et une constation
ouvrière et vivent dans des conditions
épouvantables de l'époque et rivière
pilote si vous voulez vie avec un pilote
vient béquille qui s'appelle un codé qui
profitait à d'habitation la monnaie qui
était aussi une sucrerie à l'époque
et pendant cette période évidemment écho
dès ce matin puisque chaque année même
période initiale du hameau à l'issue son
usine est évidemment son but est de 3 et
alice donc un incident
cela ou du maroc on a vu grand fond
entre martinique et en utilisant un
colonialisme collomb et son ami français
fonctionnaires entraîne petite bagarre
le colon n'est pas condamné le
martiniquais l'ubs et on sait qu il est
condamné à cinq ans de bagne ce camp de
ban pourquoi possiblement le code pénal
trouvait à l'époque que tout descendants
afrodescendants condamné à cinq ans
d'emprisonnement devait automatiquement
au bagne non le banc de bienne
là il est donc envoyé au bagne et c'est
le condamné au bagne et c'est cette
condamnation qui va déclencher la colère
la population exactement
cette obligation qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
être la condamnation évidemment unique
puisqu'il a fait appel et est dégoûté
d'aisément et/ou vinik aussi parce que
le betico des d'autres parlaient
s'éventaient d'état c'est un assesseur
imminente se vantait d'avoir condamné un
on ne voit-il pas que nous sommes 70 la
mi-septembre et l'armée de napoléon iii
prix d'abord victoire à sedan densité
des fêtes et les défaites et 4 défaites
qu'est ce qu'on voit et bloque une masse
de population
dirigée par monsieur telle qu'un kit -
propriétaire et qui est quand même
monsieur relativement riche et qui dit
que les blancs assez profité des noirs
qu'il faut mettre fin à cette
exploitation
mais il faut savoir que pendant toute
cette période toutes les écoles sont
fermées et il ya un groupe de jeunes du
jeune pilote un ancien enseignant de
désintérêt que de l'époque qui avait pas
un petit club flows offic et guy
discutaient des comptes et libertés des
possibilités dès l'entrée l'athlète
votre hôtel gas gas gas qu'un non pas la
cas la question des campagnes tout le
gage et remy géant mère beaux livres
acquis damas se sont et doivent ict et
ce sont des jeunes du bourg devient
pratiquement tous mulâtre il a encore
rappelé me la télévente et et discutent
et lors des événements radio
qu'ils apprennent que la république
était programmée en france et tout de
suite ils se rassemblent et on voit lui
aviez belote
des centaines de personnes s'appelle
l'armée de tels gains qui arrivent et
qui dit voilà vive le prussien vue là
blick
ils demandent évidemment la libération
immédiate de lubin pas quand
l'arrestation de godets d'accord et les
mises à plat des libertés les libertés
publiques l'ouverture d'écoles etc alors
au départ si vous voulez les maires qui
s'appelait goût des ombres qui 2000
lettres le nom qu'on a devient au quidam
il est
c'est un col hôpitaux reconnaît deux
grands pots il ne faut pas ça au sérieux
mais fait appel quand même la milice est
alarmé petite garnison que marin qui est
tout de suite désormais et arrive au
même moment l'ami de l'accueil
l'accueil que d'un moyen politique de
rigueur qui descend aussi actionnaire
mais déjà en mai depuis que de coupes la
socgen le beau et tout de suite devant
les événements
le maire au recul c'est en mai de
monomères de désarmer et les békés du
bon ceux qui disent ce qu'ils font les
gens dangeraux qu ils partent ils
laissent le beau et tout de suite 7 ans
mais gonflé de plusieurs centaines de
personnes venues toutes les campagnes
à l'époque il n'est pas de bois de sapin
et sa gamme sort au groupe et pas avec
l'harmonie et la money et pourquoi pas
c'est pour retrouver godet goudé n'est
plus là et god évidemment s'échappe dans
lemon dont ici ce monde qui des boisés
il y avait un champ de bakwa à côté et
il est retrouvé
il est retrouvé et il éxécuté par des
insurgés et a pas de ce moment des
succès de man couvre l'ensemble du sud
quand vous voyez bien le nombre
d'habitations sont touchés au marais au
vauclin ivey pilote via sahel et au sens
d'aller au diamant fort de france a
débuté sa tristesse que l'habitation
daumesnil et jean 5 25 25 étaient
touchés
on sait qu'avec des essaims duo robert
c'est à dire combien de temps les la
phase de l'instruction de huit jours
d'accord et après la répression puisque
les ministres sont glissés ainsi qu'à
l'armée c'est que la marine d'accord
envahissent le sud surtout via pilotes
l'insurrection évidemment jubilé la
dernière bataille la bataille de sept
inscrits habitations mobiles et la
battère dégage le contrat chez de la
caille ceux des deux grandes batailles
où il ya des manques d exécution le
procès qui a duré pratiquement un an a
déclenché une série d'événements en
martinique et dans le sud puisque les
habitations continuer à brûler et à ses
pieds à la fin la grange cette
expression et de la politique économique
et militaire a donné cette épopée qui
est très mal connue mantecon après les
succès du sud et que tous les mardis qui
devrait connaître la mesure vous
imaginez qu'à l'époque des centaines de
matic parce qu'il ya ici son arrestation
il ya eu onze condamnations à mort il ya
eu plus de 100 condamnations criminelles
ou ban
lena qui ont été mis au ban des
canonniers avec louise michel et la
commune de paris vous imaginez l'ampleur
de ce mouvement qui a modifié le paysage
politique économique de la martinique
après cette période parce que les insa
cas sont ouvertes il ya eu des élections
le conseil général est en majorité aux
revenus aux mains des couches
supérieures de la population et
l'émulation un peu limite à dire combien
sont les quelques intellectuels qui
existait donc il ya une modification
paysage politique et le lot sur
l'objectif qui est bien c'est
l'instruction des créations d'écoles
création d'écoles maîtrisant sa classe
est important une vie culturelle plus
décentes aux vertus de bibliothèque
c'est ça les réclamations il s'adonnait
cette martinique nouvelle qui pendant
plus de 100 ans a modifié un mot de
livres dans cette nouvelle élite
évidemment qui ont permis aux moitié
aujourd'hui de ce que nous sommes